[Musique étrangère]
connaissez-vous ce sentiment lorsque vous
faites exactement ce que vous avez été mis sur
terre pour faire celui où c'est comme si
tout en vous bougeait
en harmonie avec l'univers,
moi non plus
mais vous savez qu'on peut espérer la bonne
vague  à maman parce qu'elle me détestera
encore plus qu'elle ne le fait déjà si tu
ne le fais pas, je crois me souvenir que tu as dit que
devenir avocat ne ferait que t'écraser l'
âme ouais, c'est vrai,
je dirige une entreprise et en ce moment,
cette entreprise est en train de devenir  un journaliste dans
et hors de pagonia
[Musique]
c'est un cas unique non non et non
qui est journaliste j'ai démissionné de mon
poste ici
leçon 20 mille dit vous êtes les
bienvenus à Bologne président finaga si
ravi de vous rencontrer
vous devez prendre un selfie
vous  approuvé, il
y a tellement de choses merveilleuses à propos de
mon pays, un
étranger,
reste ici,
qu'est-ce qui vient de se passer, tu es un
homme, les services de sécurité sont arrivés, c'est un
humain, je ne suis pas le président d'un pays
en plein coup d'État, c'est le
scoop d'un  toute ta vie tu dois être en vie
pour avoir un scoop toute ta vie
tu n'aurais jamais dû venir allons-y, je
ne peux pas le laisser [
Musique]
prêt à partir je ne sais pas comment m'arrêter
quand tu commences au bas
je suis juste  faire mon travail
de moins en moins honnêtement
mesdames
le temps d'être coach [ __ ] mec
oh mon Dieu
Colore-moi impressionné M. petite
pas petite du tout dis-
moi que tu as réussi cette course
[Musique]